[Music]
well I just watched IO pyo 420s video on
the Haram genre and I thought I'd give
my two cents on the matter now from what
I got Haram in a nutshells usually were
AAL depressed young malale is turn into
a section of Eagle women who for reasons
said even the Divine logic of Albert
Einstein can explain lose any sexual
encounters with the main character
despite the fact that half naked women
are practically falling on his lap every
turn carrying a sign saying I'm single
desperate and lonely now ad cavage B
enough to lose your remote controling
enough panty shots to fill an entire
Year's worth of Victorious secret
magazines a sufficient volume of nose
beds to fill the entire Atlantic Ocean
and you have your formula for your
typical har anyway well actually I could
have described that so much quicker by
just pointing to Laina and saying pretty
much that okay so what's I appealing
about this genre well harm is a j that
has quite a bad reputation stalking it
but why wouldn't it on the outside it
looks like a cheap attempt to put
borderline nudity in the show while
watching a male Le make a complete [__]
of himself in front of a bunch of
one-dimensional women over and over and
over and over and over again but if you
try to look deep in this it's not that
much different as well now I'm the first
to admit that the genre isn't doing
itself any favors but I think the whole
genre is just for fun and shouldn't be
taken too seriously think of it as a
light fruit dessert after a heavy three
course meal it's sometimes refreshing to
watch a minor show about Jack to guy
trying to score after you just watch
something like say evangelon which makes
me want to sliit my wrist and listen to
Marilyn Manson so about the fan service
in this genre is it all necessary well I
would say that if you remove all fan
service from the Haron genre you will
lose about 90% of its appeal not saying
that harams can't be good without fan
service but as IO Saker said the Target
demographic is likely hormon charge
desperate guys AKA your stereotypical
anime geek see give a geek the prospects
of boobies and panties and I rush over
like a group of piss heads who just
emerged from their local pop and caught
a whiff of anian takeaway by digress I
think I speak for most guys of my age at
least and that my hormones will more
power than my brain ever will in my
tasting just about everything so if
adding some fan over will double the
ratings then you bet your ass that the
creators will put it in this doesn't
just apply to Haram just about every
genre aim the G has a bit of fan service
in it whether it's done Tastefully it's
up to the anime not just in anime even
sex can be found anywhere these days
whether it be in TV ads music videos or
the video game industry I think the
point I was trying to make in this long
disjointed monologue is that sex Sals
even in two dimensions and just because
an anime has fan service in it doesn't
mean it's bad having said that I do
agree that there can be too much fanto
is to the extent you come out of
watching an anime feeling like you just
watch a pedefile training video now as
for the cheapness and repetitiveness of
the whole genre I would say that no
different from any other genres out
there every genre is riddled with
repetitiveness since at the point R out
just about everything has been done
before there's so much anime out there
but most of them are just a big steaming
pile of dog dir though you do
occasionally find a gleaming gem inside
the river of [__] A Haram genre being no
different from Shonen shjo Meer and so
on since I can name stereotypes for all
those genres in the end it comes down to
personal taste as far as depth and
character development goes though I do
agree that some harams are too shallow I
know I use lafina as an example for your
typical Haram anime but I have to say
lafina is one of the few harams I
actually liked the thing that sets it
apart from other harons is the depth and
the character development that and maybe
kenak maru's Godlike ability to
endlessly create scenario in which
female clothing is ripped off while said
female is almost certainly being
inappropriately manhandled by the main
character h on second thought character
development sounds like a much more
feasable argument the characters
actually changed during the course of
this show and it's a welcome change to
the usual kbo cut at less who have as
much depth as a shallow wind in a
paddling pool I don't think there's any
real need for Innovation though as much
as I love a deep complicated storyline
adding Haram to the fry would mix about
as well as Chinese food and cheese there
wouldn't be enough time to give any
characters World depth of development
see the thing I can at least appreciate
about Haram is that it's not trying to
be something that it's not it never
hides a fact is trying to appeal to a
bunch of hormony charged teenagers who
have their brains stored and their balls
overall I would say that the genre is
not in any need for drastic changes I
wouldn't say it's good by any means but
I seen a problem with leaving it the way
it is as the lonely repressed love child
of the anime industry that sits in the
corner where no one pays much attention
to all I really want is
girls and in the morning it's
girls cuz in the evening it's gone